So we get a lot of questions about
being a mentor.
What does it mean to be a mentor, will you be my mentor, will I be your mentor?
Things like that.
Here's what I've learned about mentorship.
Mentorship is not something you ask
somebody to do like,
"Will you be my friend?"
It doesn't work like that.
When you find somebody you get along with
you share values, you share beliefs.
You spend time with them, you get to know
them.
You develop trust, you're vulnerable with
them, you open up to them.
And you discover that you become friends,
it's what happens.
You start off as simply acquaintances.
In my experience, mentorship is
exactly the same.
There were people who were much more experienced
than me who had wisdom that I didn't have
and when I would call them, they would
take my calls.
And when I would ask them questions, they
would always take the time to give me answers.
And over the course of time, they became
my mentors.
Like they became my friends.
And I remember one time I was with one of
my mentors, Ron Bruder, an amazing guy,
and I was leaving his house and I put my arm around
him and I said,
"You know, I'm glad you're my mentor,"
and he looked at me and he said,
"I'm glad you're mine."
And it caught me completely off guard.
True mentorship, like true friendship, is
not a one way street.
It's not about one person only giving advice
to the other.
Both people are showing up to give and both
people are showing up to learn.
But you can't ask someone to be your mentor,
especially someone who's a total stranger,
knock on their door and say, "Will you be
my mentor?" if they don't know you
and you've never met them.
It's like friendship.
You cultivate a relationship and if that person
is always there for you and wants to see you
thrive and succeed and believes in you,
then perhaps they will become your mentor,
like making a friend.